now check in with house oversight
committee chairman James Comer he had a
big win today the FBI director
Christopher Ray is now allowing his
entire committee to view a document that
includes allegations that President
Biden was involved in a bribery scheme
with a foreign government we know go we
now go to Fox News correspondent Kevin
Cork first
oh apparently we have James Comer first
okay anyway uh anyway Congressman Comer
thank you and you know let's talk about
specifically you know you were just
about to as of today or yesterday bring
the director director Ray into contempt
to Congress it became unnecessary
because he finally gave in to your
demand now my understanding is that this
particular
uh source that you cited in your
original letter along with Charles
Grassley is viewed as a very credible
Source the allegation seems real they
apparently have had it since 2017 it
deals specifically with the country
Ukraine and it talks about specific
actions that Joe Biden might have taken
in exchange for a lot of money what
specifically can you tell us
well I can tell you that the FBI has had
this since 2017. this particular 1023
that I was able to Grant access for my
entire committee today it's dated June
30th of uh 2020 but what you go back
through the document and their footnotes
that reference uh two prior years so
they were communicating with this paid
informant for years and according to the
FBI this is one of the most highest paid
most respected most trusted most
effective human informants so what we
learned is what the whistleblowers told
Senator Grassley all along the FBI never
investigated this but we did learn that
attorney general Barr when he received
this this particular 1023 that was uh up
for viewing today for the house
oversight committee he passed it along
to the U.S attorney in Delaware who was
investigating Hunter Biden and remember
this this 1023 didn't just implicate Joe
Biden it also implicated his son so
what's interesting to me when I read the
document was the fact that this was
years before our work on the oversight
committee brought out the fact that the
Biden family were using multiple Banks
and multiple shell companies to launder
money from foreign Nationals no one knew
about this back in 2020. this has only
become a relevation Revelation since our
committee has brought it to like in the
last few months so no one knew about
these shell companies but it
specifically says by their trusted human
informant that the the pay the the payor
of these bribes bragged that the way
Biden wanted the money distributed it
would be through so many banks that it
would take investigators 10 years to
track the money and I can tell you Sean
it's taken us a long time to track the
money but we are tracking the money
we're finding money from China we found
money from Romania and we will find this
money from Ukraine
so you you believe there's a total of 10
million dollars involved in all of this
and and this has been ongoing since 2017
and the FBI's had this the whole time
and they've never done a full
investigation into this
that's that's what it appears to be now
what attorney general Barr said he
passed it along to the U.S attorney in
Delaware my theory Sean is that the U.S
attorney in Delaware had never even
really paid attention to this until the
last two weeks now according to the FBI
when I had that private briefing with
Jamie raskins who had to feel
uncomfortable sitting in there listening
to all of that information that we were
being
that we were receiving from the FBI
considering he led an impeachment of
Donald Trump for simply asking about
corruption in Ukraine the FBI is talking
about all these credible accusations
they have with respect to corruption in
Ukraine from the Biden family we believe
that that these banks will will
will show that they were trade that the
money was laundered through shell
companies more shell companies so uh
we're we're going to continue to to try
to subpoena the bank Congressman we're
looking for more shell companies yes
all right Americans now watched Hillary
Clinton with top secret classified
information on our servers and and but
no prosecutor would prosecute they watch
quote obstruction uh by the deletion of
33 000 subpunity males and the
destruction of devices uh that might
have had some of that information on
them uh nobody seemed to get you know
upset or in any way shaped manner reform
uh now you've got four separate
locations top secret classified
information with Joe Biden okay they
raid Mar-A-Lago they didn't rate
Chappaqua they didn't raid Delaware that
didn't raid UPenn they didn't raid the
beach house but it's Donald Trump that
has Mar-A-Lago rated and Donald Trump
that gets charged for what seems like
the exact same allegations do you see
much difference
no uh look Joe Biden has mishandled
classified documents in a much more
severe manner than Donald Trump ever
mishandled classified documents what
we've learned about this form 1023 again
the FBI never investigated it but
there's this is a pattern of the FBI not
investigating anything with respect to
to Biden look at what they had with the
steel dossier which was no credible
Source compared to what they have with
this 1023 on Joe Biden from their most
trusted credible source and then Sean I
want you to think about this two things
first of all they wouldn't even admit
that this document existed until Senator
Grassley and I told Christopher Wray
that we had already read the document
from The Whistleblower so then once I
got to view the document it was apparent
there were more documents then as early
as Monday when they gave me the briefing
for 90 minutes the FBI tried to say
there were no more documents when we
were negotiating last night on
postponing this uh this motion to hold
them in contempt they finally admitted
there are more 1023s on Biden and
bribery and they're going to let me see
those now so we're making progress with
with the FBI the FBI clearly has treated
uh Joe Biden very differently than
they're treating Donald Trump but
thankfully for the American people the
house oversight committee is on top of
this we we're uncovering the banks
these are things that we will continue
to push forward on
based on all these LLCs that you keep
describing and the amount of money
that's being shifted Around Here There
and Everywhere and the number of
countries that you've identified that
the Biden family was doing business with
and you're right about the Ukraine issue
because Joe bragged about leveraging a
billion dollars uh demanding a prosecute
prosecutor be fired in six hours
prosecutor turns out to be investigating
his son and the company paying him a
fortune barisma uh the Barista energy
giant so at the end of the day my
question to you do you have any earthly
idea how many millions of dollars we
might be talking about between Hunter
and Devin Archer and Joe Biden and the
nine family members that you say
ultimately got payments as well and
including apparently grandkids they must
be where it must be very smart if
they're getting some of the money as
well
well it's it's consistent with organized
crime you've got racketeering you've got
money laundering you've got bribery but
I would estimate Sean that we we've
already uncovered 10 million I would say
that number could top out at 20 million
plus when this is all said and done
we're going to continue to focus we've
got more banks that we're focusing in on
with subpoenas and just the last thing
Sean think about this according to Bill
Barr and according to FBI
this 10 23 being passed over to the U.S
attorney in Delaware means that Joe
Biden is currently under investigation
for bribery by a U.S attorney now I know
that gets Lost in Translation but that's
what Bill Barr and the FBI said that
that document is in the hands of the U.S
attorney in Delaware
it is interesting that the doj charging
president Trump
um on this issue of classified documents
they haven't been particularly
Cooperative the FBI and the doj with
your request be it for suspicious
activity reports or this 1023 form they
have not been particularly cooperative
and forthcoming with information and
you've spent like pulling teeth we
appreciate your time sir thank you hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else